RIGHT, HERE WE GO.
NOW I'M GOING TO BLOW YOUR
MIND
AND THIS, LET ME LET ME
GIVE YOU THE FULL
EXPERIENCE
THAT CAUSED ME TO COME TO THIS
CONCLUSION
TUESDAY
OF THIS WEEK. THE LEAGUE IN
THE UNION
FINALIZED, A
SEVEN-PAGE LETTER
AGREEMENT,
SETTING FORTH THE RULES FOR
THE COVID OPT OUT THIS SEASON.
AND MY FIRST THOUGHT, WAS WHY
BOTHER
WHO THE HELL IS OPTING OUT
THIS YEAR?
67 GUYS. OPTED OUT
LAST YEAR AND I THINK ONE OF
THE REASONS SO MANY DID
SO MUCH UNCERTAINTY
BEFORE THEIR DEADLINE OF LIKE
EARLY AUGUST. NOBODY HAD A
CHANCE TO COME TO TRAINING
CAMP AND GIVE IT A WEEK OR TWO
AND SEE HOW THEY FELT OR GIVE
ME A COUPLE OF SEASONS OR
COUPLE OF WEEKS. EXCUSE ME,
INTO THE REGULAR SEASON.
LET ME DECIDE. THEN HOW IT
FEELS. YOU HAD TO MAKE AN
EARLY DECISION.
67.
GUYS DID I'D SAY MOST OF
THEM REGRET IT IN HINDSIGHT
THE WAY THINGS WENT THIS YEAR.
I BOTHER, WHO THE HELL IS
OPTING OUT?
OKAY.
THAT SAID,
I READ THE LETTER AGREEMENT
YESTERDAY AND IT'S, YOU KNOW,
LEGALESE AND
THICK AND
YEAH, READ IT CAREFULLY. AND
AS I WAS READING IT, I'M
THINKING,
OKAY,
I COULD SEE
COLE BEASLEY OPTING OUT
BECAUSE
I'M NOT GETTING VACCINATED
AND I DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THE RULES THAT APPLY
TO PLAYERS WHO AREN'T
VACCINATED. SO THIS IS A WAY
FOR ME TO
TO PRESS PAUSE ON.
CAREER. I'LL COME BACK NEXT
YEAR WHEN THIS ISN'T AN ISSUE.
THAT'S
ONE ONE GUY. I COULD THINK OF
THAT WOULD TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THIS AND THEN I THOUGHT OF
AARON RODGERS, THIS IS A
GET OUT OF JAIL FREE CARD.
THIS IS A SILVER BULLET FOR
HIM WHERE HE CAN OPT OUT.
TAKE THE ENTIRE YEAR OFF.
NATTO THE GREEN BAY PACKERS
11 AND A HALF MILLION IN
UNEARNED SIGNING, BONUS MONEY,
NOT OWE THEM TO MILLION IN
FINES THAT WILL ACCRUE IF HE
SKIPS TRAINING CAMP, NOT
FORFEIT, THE 6.8 MILLION
DOLLAR ROSTER BONUS THAT HE'S
ALREADY EARNED AND WILL BE
PAID OUT THIS YEAR.
YEAR. IT'S 20
THREE MILLION TOTAL
THAT HE WOULD AVOID IF HE HOPS
OUT AND AND
WHAT I DID
ONCE I
REALIZED THAT THAT POWER IS
THERE.
I TRIED TO FIND A REASON TO
CONVINCE MYSELF. IT'S NOT
SO I
FOUND SOME LANGUAGE IN THE
AGREEMENT
THAT MADE ME THINK HE CAN'T DO
IT. IT'S TOO EASY. IT'S TOO
SIMPLE.
AND,
AND
I WENT BACK AND FORTH WITH
SOMEONE OVER NIGHT AND I
LOOKED AT THE LETTER AGREEMENT
AGAIN THIS MORNING AND YOU
KNOW WHAT HE CAN
HE HAS
TO MAKE AN
REVOCABLE DECISION BY NEXT
FRIDAY
YOU. AND, AND, AND THAT'S IT.
IT IS
FINAL.
BUT IF HE DECIDES
AND INFORMS THE TEAM BY NEXT
FRIDAY, JULY 2ND THAT
HE'S SITTING OUT FOR ALL
THE 2021 TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THE OPT-OUT, RIGHT?
HE SAVES
20 POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
AND
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN NEXT YEAR
THEY TRADE HIM, WE GET TO
WHERE WE WOULD HAVE BEEN
ANYWAY,
I DON'T
I THINK HE'S GOING TO DO IT,
BUT IT'S AMAZING TO THINK HE
HAS A PATH. IF HE'S TRULY
THINKING ABOUT SITTING OUT HE
HAS A PATH TO DO IT.
THAT SAVES HIM.
20 POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS.
REMEMBER
WHAT WAS THE SHOW CALLED? IT
WAS
LIFE LIFESTYLES OF THE RICH
AND FAMOUS
WITH ROBIN LEACH, RIGHT?
YES, I WISH THEY DID THAT FOR
YOU
LIFESTYLES OF THE RICH AND
FAMOUS AND THEY SHOWED UP TO
THE BARN AND IT'S JUST
PAPER AND EVERYWHERE BE VERY
PAPER EVERYWHERE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT AARON RODGERS
LOOPHOLE
LOFT.
OPT OUT FOR THE COVID PROTOCOL
AND THAT'S HOW MIKE FLORIO
SENT HIS SPENT. HIS THURSDAY.
IT WAS FANTASTIC. YEAH, THAT
WAS JUST DOING GENERATE THAT
WOULD GENERATE
EXOTIC CHARLIE KELLY WITH
CHECK MET SYLVIA YOU'RE JUST
YOU'RE PUTTING THE
PINS. WE GOT
WORD, WE GOT HERE. IT IS THAT
WE GOT IT. THERE IT IS.
HERE'S SEE MIKE. LISTEN, I
HOPE YOU'RE RIGHT.
I HOPE YOU'RE RIGHT.
BUT
OH MAN, THAT
KNOW THAT WAS THE WORST WAY TO
SPEND YOUR TIME
EVER.
IT'S NOT. NO, IT'S NOT,
NO, IT'S NOT BECAUSE IF HE
DOESN'T IF HE DOES IT, I WAS
THE ONLY ONE SAYING THAT HE
MAY DO IT.
AND AND ONE OF THEM,
I GUESS WHAT YOU GET, GUESS
WHAT? YOU GET A LITTLE TINY
TROPHY OF VALIDATION THAT YOU
SHE'S BEING LIKE, OH, MIKE,
YOU KNOW, WHO'S GONNA STEAL
IT?
I DON'T HAVE TO TELL YOU WHO'S
GONNA STEAL IT, BUT OTHER
PEOPLE WILL DEFINITELY STEAL
THIS TAKE MIKE AND THEY'LL
PROBABLY GET MORE CREDIT FOR
IT.
THAT'S ALRIGHT. THAT'S ALRIGHT
BECAUSE I'M ONLY
TRYING TO PROVE IT TO MYSELF
GOD, I'M NOT TRYING TO PROVE
IT TO ANYONE ELSE BUT
I
LOVE THAT. YOU DID THE WORK.
IT REALLY DIDN'T TAKE THAT
MUCH WORK
WOULD HAVE GOTTEN IT RIGHT
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON, I WAS
TRYING SO DAMN HARD
TO NOT GO THERE YESTERDAY.
IT'S LIKE THERE'S NO WAY. THIS
IS TOO EASY. THIS IS
TO SIMPLE. THERE'S NO WAY I'M
TRYING TO SPEAK IT INTO
EXISTENCE.
NOT, NOT BECAUSE I
CARE WHETHER OR NOT HE PLAYS
THIS YEAR. I ACTUALLY THINK
IT'S BETTER FOR OUR
BUSINESS IF HE DOES PLAY FOR
THE PACKERS BECAUSE THE
DYSFUNCTION WILL JUST BE
JUST BE
WALL-TO-WALL.
FROM THE MOMENT, HE SHOWS UP
UNTIL THE MOMENT THEIR SEASON
ENDS, BUT IF HE
IS GOING
TO STAY AWAY IF THAT'S
WHAT HE'S INTENDING TO DO,
HE HAD FALLEN TO HIS LAP ON
TUESDAY, THE ULTIMATE WAY TO
DO IT WITHOUT
LOSING
TWENTY POINT THREE MILLION.
SO
I LOOK AT IT THIS WAY,
IF HE
DOESN'T
OPT OUT BY NEXT FRIDAY,
THEN THAT MEANS HE IS SHOWING
UP AND HE WAS GOING TO SHOW UP
ALL ALONG.
OKAY.
SO
I LOVE THAT YOU DID THIS.
I NOW HAVE NEXT
FRIDAY CIRCLED HOPING THAT HE
OPTS OUT FOR
MENTAL HEALTH,
I WANT TO DO IT. I WANT TO BE
HAPPY.
LET'S GO BACK. LET'S FRAME IT
IN THE TOM BRADY CONVERSATION.
WE JUST HAD
IF HE DID OPT OUT.
WHAT DOES THAT DO TO AARON
RODGERS LEGACY? BECAUSE THAT
OBVIOUSLY
CHANGES
CHANGES THINGS. IF HE
I DON'T WANT TO PLAY
AND PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW
HOW PEOPLE FEEL ABOUT
COVID NOW
AND NOW THAT WE'RE ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE PIN DEMIC
AND IF HE USES IT UNDER THE
GUISE OF
COVID PROTOCOL BECAUSE
THAT'S KIND OF HOW WE WILL
HAVE TO PLAY IT. RIGHT. LIKE
HE CAN'T SAY I'M
THE OPTING OUT
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO PLAY
FOR THE GREEN BAY PACKERS.
HE'S SAYING I'M USING NOT
COVID PROTOCOL AND I'M USING
THE RULES THAT ARE SET FORTH
BY THE NFL, AND I'M
OPTING OUT
BEFORE SAFETY
ISSUE.
IT WOULD BE A DIFFICULT
PR CELL, RIGHT? AND I THINK
WHAT HE WOULD HAVE TO DO
IS AND HERE'S HOW I THINK
HE'D HAVE TO COUCH IT.
I THINK YOU'D HAVE TO SAY I'M
NOT DOING THIS BECAUSE I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT COVID BECAUSE
THE WEEKEND IS NOT HAVE TO BE
CONCERNED,
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT COVID. YOU HAVE A
VOLUNTARY
OPT-OUT, RIGHT? THAT HE'S, BUT
THAT'S WHY I DIDN'T BELIEVE IT
YESTERDAY. THAT'S WHY I DIDN'T
WANT TO BELIEVE IT YESTERDAY.
I WANTED TO READ THE
AGREEMENT
TO
CONCLUDE THAT HE COULD ONLY DO
IT. IF HE HAD DEVELOPED
SOME SORT OF A CONDITION,
SINCE LAST OCTOBER THAT PUTS
HIM IN A HIGH-RISK CATEGORY
AND THAT'S TRUE, IF YOU WANT
TO GET A
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR STIPEND FOR HIM WHO
GIVES A CRAP ABOUT THE STIPEND
HE'S TRYING TO AVOID MOWING
$350,000 STIPEND FOR HIM WHO
GIVES A CRAP ABOUT THE
STIPEND, HE'S TRYING TO AVOID
OWING. THE PACKERS 20.
THREE MILLION. WHAT HE WOULD
HAVE TO DO IS SIT DOWN
WITH A FAVORABLE INTERVIEWER.
AND
EXPLAIN WITHOUT GETTING A
BUNCH OF TOUGH QUESTIONS.
YEAH YOU OF COURSE
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO DO IS SAY
LOOK HERE'S HOW THE NFL
WORKS. THERE'S A BUNCH OF
RULES OUT THERE THAT
TYPICALLY ARE
WRITTEN FOR THE BENEFIT
OF THE TEAMS AND THEY PUT
PRESSURE ON THE PLAYERS TO
DO THINGS THAT MAYBE THE
PLAYERS DON'T WANT TO DO AND
I'M IN THE PROCESS OF TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT. DO I WANT TO
PLAY?
OR THE GREEN BAY PACKERS
THIS YEAR. AND I HAD A RULE
FALL OUT OF THE SKY THAT THE
NFL, THE NFL PA
NEGOTIATED.
AND THE WAY THAT I'M READING
IT AND THE WAY THAT MY
AGENTS ARE READING IT, IT
GIVES ME THE ABILITY TO DO
WHAT I WAS GOING TO DO ANYWAY,
WITHOUT OWING THE PACKERS
A BUNCH OF MONEY THAT I'VE
ALREADY BEEN PAID OR THAT I'M
ALREADY ENTITLED TO.
WE PRESS PAUSE ON THE
RELATIONSHIP FOR A YEAR,
SO THAT'S WHAT WE DO
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M DOING. I'M
DOING WHAT I'M DOING IS NO
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT THE TEAM
DOES WHEN THEY CUT A GUY
FROM THE ROSTER.
WHEN THEY, WHEN THEY WHATEVER
THE WHATEVER RIGHTS OF TEAM
HAS APPLYING THE FRANCHISE
TAG. THAT'S A RIGHT THAT
ARISES IN THE RULES AT
THIS TWO SIDES OF PUT
TOGETHER. IT'S NOT AN EASY
ARGUMENT
FORM TO MAKE AND THERE'S GONNA
BE A LOT OF PACKERS FANS THAT
AREN'T GOING TO LIKE IT. BUT
MY POINT IS THIS, IF HE'S NOT
GOING TO PLAY ANYWAY,
IF HE'S ALREADY DECIDED, I'M
NOT SHOWING UP THIS YEAR.
IT'S IT'S RIDICULOUS.
FOR HIM TO NOT TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF A PATH THAT
AVOIDS, A
20 POINT THREE MILLION DOLLAR
DIFFERENCE.
IF HE
JUST STAYS AWAY ALL YEAR LONG
VERSUS IF HE HOPS OUT BY NEXT
FRIDAY, THAT'S MY POINT. YEAH,
FOR TWENTY POINT THREE
MILLION YOU CAN GO
HIGHER. THE BEST PR FIRM IN
THE WORLD
TO GIVE YOU A WAY TO EXPLAIN
WHY YOU'RE DOING WHAT YOU'RE
DOING.
OKAY, ANOTHER QUESTION IF
HE DOES OPT OUT ON
FRIDAY BY FRIDAY. NEXT FRIDAY.
THERE'S NO CHANCE. HE CAN COME
BACK THIS YEAR,
CORRECT IS IT AIN'T, IT'S
DONE. OKAY, SO
THAT'S WHY I THINK HE'S NOT
GOING TO DO IT BECAUSE I THINK
IN THE BACK OF HIS HEAD, HE'S
SAYING TO HIMSELF.
IF I
JUST KEEP
SEEING THIS, THE PACKERS WILL
EVENTUALLY TRADE ME. AND IF
THEY DON'T TRADE ME, I'LL JUST
PLAY FOOTBALL, AND I'LL JUST
HATE EVERYONE AND NOT TALK TO
ANYONE IN THAT FACILITY
AND BE AARON RODGERS AND MAKE
A LOT OF MONEY AND PROBABLY
WIN A BUNCH OF GAMES
AND LOSING AN NFC
PLAYOFF GAME AND BLAME
EVERYONE, BUT MYSELF
AND CALL IT A YEAR AND THEN
FIGURE IT OUT NEXT YEAR.
THAT'S PROBABLY WHAT HILDA,
THAT'S
HEY THAT'S WHY RUSSELL.
WILSON'S BACK IN SEATTLE,
THERE WAS A REPORT FROM ESPN
EARLIER THIS WEEK THAT RUSSELL
WILSON'S HAPPY NOW AND HE'S
ALL IN. YEAH, FOR NOW
BECAUSE HE
UNDERSTANDS,
THIS YEAR IS ANOTHER
ROLL OF THE DICE. IT'S ANOTHER
SPIN OF THE WHEEL TO TRY TO
ADD TO YOUR LEGACY
AND RUSSELL WILSON'S. GOT A
HELL OF A LOT MORE OF THOSE
SPINS LEFT THAN AARON
RODGERS. AARON RODGERS IS DOWN
TO, LET'S SAY FOR YOU. GOING
TO GIVE UP ONE, DON'T KNOW,
YOU DON'T
LIKE HIM. YOU DON'T LIKE
US. YOU DON'T DO THE TIME
ANYMORE.
TOM, BRADY HAS RUINED THAT FOR
EVERYONE. YOU CAN'T.
LOOK HEHE. IF
AARON RODGERS WANTS TO ADD TO
HIS LEGACY, HE CAN'T GIVE UP A
FULL SEASON OF FOOTBALL AND
AND IF HIS PROBLEM IN GREEN
BAY IS,
I DON'T LIKE UPPER
MANAGEMENT AS I'VE SAID MANY
TIMES THIS WEEK WITH THE
CAVEAT THAT
THAT I HAVE NO ISSUE WITH
UPPER MANAGEMENT AT NBC,
I'D SAY MOST AMERICANS
HAVE AN ISSUE WITH UPPER
MANAGEMENT, WHEREVER THEY WORK
AND THEY STILL SHOW UP TO WORK
EVERY DAY. SO JUST BECAUSE
HE'S UPSET WITH MARC MURPHY
OR BRIAN GUDYKUNST HE SAID TO
KENNY MAIN I LOVE MY
TEAMMATES ALL MY COACHES. ALL
OF THE FANS EITHER HE'S GOING
TO BE THERE BUT IF HE'S
ALREADY DECIDED
THE PIN ON THE GRENADE IS